[Musique]
on
bonsoir ou re bonsoir à tous il est 22
heures pile ou vpn ou vpn spéciale en
direct sur public sénat on est ensemble
pendant une heure on va revenir en
longueur sur l'intervention du chef de
l'état chez nos confrères de tf1 les
gilets jaunes les relations
franco-américaines sa relation avec les
français
autant de sujets majeurs abordés par le
président français attaqué de toutes
parts il y répond il comprend la colère
il veut davantage écouter ses
compatriotes les protéger les considérer
les respecter mais attention et il le
dit à plusieurs reprises il ne changera
pas de cap
nos invités sont là pour vous aider à
comprendre et analyser tout cela je vous
les présente juste après ce sujet qui
reprend les moments forts de cette
intervention présidentielle un sujet
signé cécile 6 ou 30 minutes d'interview
emmanuel macron garde le cap
la hausse des prix du carburant il
assume même s'il dit entendre la colère
des gilet jaune et met en garde contre
les récupération politique de ce
mouvement jeudi
méfiance
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
veulent récupérer ce mouvement
pas de réponse non plus aux tweets de
donald trump
pour le président français les critiques
de son homologue américain c'est de la
politique américaine
emmanuel macron garde à son idée qu'il
faut une armée européenne une question
d'indépendance les états unis d'amérique
c'est notre allié historique et il
continuera de l'être celle allié avec
lequel on prend tous les risques avec
lequel on mène les opérations les plus
compliqués m allier ça n'est pas être le
vassal et donc pour ne pas être le
vassal
on ne doit pas dépendre d'eux est donc y
compris par rapport aux américains nous
devons dépenser davantage
nous devons faire davantage nous mêmes
en tant que français et en tant
qu'européen enfin s'il ne compte pas
changer de politique
emmanuel macron reconnaît tout de même
un échec depuis son élection
s'il ya une chose que je n'ai pas
vraiment réussi à faire
c'est je n'ai pas réussi à réconcilier
le peuple français avec ses dirigeants
et ça c'est vrai emmanuel macron a
appelé la nation à se mobiliser autour
de lui et avec nous pour s'étoffer pl
spéciale en direct ce soir sur public
sénat caroline michel aguer bonsoir
journaliste au service affaires de l'ops
l'aube ce qui sort en cuir ce que demain
avec cet hymne sur le pouvoir d'achat
qui perd qui gagne se demande l'aube
cette semaine le constat est clair
emmanuel macron ne parvient pas à
convaincre
vous avez d'ailleurs recueilli des
témoignages qui vont dans ce sens ce qui
montre que l'étiquette de président des
riches le poursuit notre émission va
aussi vous aider à savoir si tout cela
est vrai jean sébastien ferjou nous
l'attendons il arrive d'ici quelques
minutes arnaud benedetti bonsoir bonsoir
spécialiste de la communication
politique professeur associé en histoire
de la communication à l'université
sorbonne auteur du coup de com
permanents et alexia germond bonsoir à
vous également présidente fondatrice du
think tank france audacieuse hauteur de
réveillon notre europe et je vous le
disais il arrive jean sébastien ferjou
est avec nous directeur de la
publication atlantico bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous jean sébastien le sujet
sur lequel emmanuel macron était
peut-être le plus attendu ce soir c'est
celui des taxes sur les carburants
évidemment à trois jours de la
manifestation des gilets jaunes et nous
dit je comprends la colère mais la
hausse du carburant
c'est le pétrole ont rougi suis pas pour
grand chose c'est un peu le message
qu'on a compris car les michel aguer
vous êtes d'accord
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de ces
réponses sur ce sujet précis sur le
carburant en particulier et les gilet
jaune
oui il a fait un double exercice où
c'était très réussi j'ai trouvé en
réaction à ce qu'on lui avait beaucoup
reproché c'est à dire l'écoutent la
compréhension j'entends et c'est
vraiment dans la continuité de toute la
séquence de la semaine dernière et par
certains exemples on a senti qu'il avait
entendu qu'il est allé sur le terrain il
a donné des exemples et il avait l'air
sincère et je trouve que cet exercice là
de dire j'entends la souffrance je
partage l'incompréhension j'ai du
respect et de la considération pour ça
je pense que c'était quelque chose que
les français attendaient je ne dis pas
que ça va calmer les gilet jaune mais en
revanche pour tout ce qui est axé
politique fiscale je les ai trouvé
extrêmement techno et peu combatif alors
qu'il ya plein de sujets sains
on abordera sur lequel il était très
combatif il ya quelque chose qui a été
très peu repris et justement parce que
c'était très peu clair
il a dit oui mais les impôts ils
n'augmentent pas vraiment si on les
rapporte à la production et il est
rentré tout de suite dans un discours
technique
on n'a pas bien compris d'ailleurs ils
m'ont dit ça va baisser mais on n'a pas
mais oui alors c'était c'est un truc
techno de devenir en valeur relative par
rapport au pib voilà en valeur absolue
c'est ça augmente mais pas en valeur
relative et je trouve qu'il était un peu
coincé au fond c'est ce que disent les
gens il est un peu coincé sur le fond
parce que les gens ne voient pas en quoi
sa baisse et la vérité c'est que le
sentiment global c'est qu'il enlève un
peu ça pour redonner un peu là et qu'on
ne voit pas la cohérence les grands
mouvements et en effet sur ces grands
mouvements ils n'apportaient pas la
réponse ou la conviction donc un
exercice plutôt humains réussi sur
l'incarnation et le lien pour sur le cas
il beaucoup pêché en revanche sur la
politique globale et le côté oui oui ça
va baisser donnez moi du temps il a
presque imploré les saint lois du temps
je trouve ça moins qu'avec moins
convaincant arnaud benedetti vous êtes
d'accord il ya eu ce de la sincérité
entravent l'affichage de sincérité mais
aussi trop technique
mais moi j'ai vu un exercice de
blitzkrieg communicant c'est à dire on a
un format qui est très resserré avec
tous les fondamentaux du maquereau nisme
qui était à peu près décliner très
rapidement si vous les bus il y avait
les avions de chasse à côté donc on
avait un peu la métaphore dans l'avion
chasse il volé très haut très rapidement
avec beaucoup de bruit d'ailleurs votre
confrère avait du mal parfois à lui à
lui poser des questions
et la réalité c'est que finalement on
ressort de l'exercice avec un maquereau
qui sans surprise qui reste tout à fait
droit dans ses bottes concernant son
logiciel qui certes nous explique qu'il
est dans l' écoute
puisque quand même on sent bien que
depuis quelques jours il faut qu'ils
arrivent à scénariser cette capacité
cette disposition a écouté
mais quelque part ce sont des mots et je
crains que finalement le spectateur le
téléspectateur au sortir de l'exercice
se disent finalement quoi de plus par
rapport à ce que l'on sait déjà
donc est ce qui est très étonnant c'est
la séquence si vous voulez c'est que
quand même ils ont brûlé deux cartouches
enfin en 24 heures c'est à dire que vous
avez un premier ministre sur rtl ce
matin qui a lui disons annoncé un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont
censées calmer l'ardeur et la colère des
gis les jeunes et vous avez ensuite le
président de la république qui vient
faire le service après vente
ce qui est assez surprenant d'ailleurs
sur le plan institutionnel sur le plan
j'allais dire de la séquence institut du
premier du 1er minime et faillit bien
après ce qui est un peu surprenant donc
voilà c'est un peu c'est un exercice un
peu compliqué quand même je pense à
l'excès j'avance qu'on retient aussi
c'est tient effectivement il ne changera
pas de cap il ne bougera pas une ligne
de sa politique
alors on retient cela mais vous dites
que qu'emmanuel macron a été sans
surprise
moi je les trouvais quand même avec un
petit peu de surprises sur la partie en
pâtit et sur le fait de reconnaître on a
l'impression quand même que pendant sept
semaines d'itinérance mémorielle un
certain nombre de messages ont peut-être
pris corps et j'ai trouvé ça rassurant
de voir que le président avait quand
même entendu un certain nombre de choses
c'est très fort de dire je n'ai pas
réussi
oui il ne dit pas à aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs quand vous entendez la
syntaxe c'est toujours très important il
dit je n'ai pas réussi à renouer le lien
entre les citoyens et leurs dirigeants
dernières années ont leurré contrat en
longueur c'est un dd
des passages marquants de cette soirée
mais sur cette question des taxes du
carburant dv sur le cap
oui mais sur le cac en fait je crois que
toute la séquence qu'on a vécu à
vraiment ou démontrer le manque de
pédagogie en amont c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression que finalement d'un coup
ils se sont rendu compte qu'ils
n'avaient pas fait le service
après-vente qu'il fallait là je suis
assez d'accord avec vous à ces
techniques sur cette partie là pas
forcément le plus convaincant venant
faire une voiture balai après les
explications assez clair et le
communiqué de presse post
post conseil des ministres ce matin qui
était assez long pour expliquer en fait
la transition énergétique et le fait que
tout le monde allait devoir s'y coller
c'est vrai que sur la partie changement
de cap
il est aussi dans son rôle c'est à dire
qu' on ne peut pas passer son temps non
plus même s'il faut entendre mais à
tergiverser sur les sur les décisions
qui sont prises parce que ça non plus
les citoyens ne le comprendraient plus
mais alors du coup jean sébastien ferjou
est-ce qu'il la casse ou est-ce qu'il la
prolonge cette opération déminage un peu
commencé et par edouard philippe
notamment ce matin je pense pas qu'ils
la casse la prolonge sauf que la logique
que le président s'exprime alors
effectivement on peut dire après c'est
plus surprenant maïs peu importe on
pourrait considérer que le premier
ministre est dans la logistique
justement pour expliquer les détails et
que le président est là pour donner du
sens et finalement c'est là moi je
trouve qu'il pèche un peu parce que je
suis d'accord avec ce que vous disiez on
voit un émanait macron qui a changé mais
si la seule conclusion politique qu'il
tire de ses itinérances fusse-t-elle
mémorielle c'est que lui même un
problème dans son attitude je pense que
les français n'y trouvent pas leur
compte parce que la revendication des
gilet jaune à ne porte pas sur la
personnalité des mannala kron je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui se fichent
serait un peu qu emmanuel macron soit ou
pas arrogant
s'il n'avait pas de problème de manque d
coûte quand même mais je suis d'accord
avec vous
rebecca sous ce que je vous disais les
gens ce qui les préoccupe quand même
c'est leur vie à eux c'est pâques et
même macron soit plus ou moins méprisant
plus ou moins arrogant dans la manière
dont ils s'adressent à eux parce que là
il donne l'impression
je suis d'accord avec c'est une équation
politique qui est très difficile parce
que à la fois on le voit il ya pu avoir
une crainte de la part de la république
en marge de voir une partie de son
propre électorat s'enfuir vers notamment
un électorat écologiste donc renoncer
aux hausses de taxes à ce serait
s'exposer au procès de bien regarder
il cède à la pression ou sont des
girouettes d'ailleurs edouard philippe
assez habilement utilisé cet argument ce
matin là en disant nous ne faisons pas
partie de ceux qui se font élire sur une
promesse pour derrière réclamer l'
inverse 18 mois dix-huit mois plus tard
sauf que ce faisant ce qui est plutôt
courageux peut-être par rapport à leur
propre électorat les condamne une forme
d'impasse sociologique parce que tous
les autres ne peuvent pas se retrouver
dans ce discours là donc emmanuel macron
il part d'une base sociologique
électorat qui est déjà relativement
faible qui sait et niété au fil du temps
et il se condamne finalement un aller
chercher personne d'autre justement avec
ce discours de je suis droit dans mes
bottes
parce que je pense que les gilet jaune
ça dépasse de très loin la question de
la fiscalité économique et ça dépasse de
très loin la question de l'essence
c'est une crise du sens c'est vraiment
une crise du sens et les gens la
question n'est pas celle c'est pour ça
je suis d'accord avec ce que vous disiez
c'est quand même épouvantable le mans
technocratique dur mais ne vous
inquiétez pas vous en plomb pas beaucoup
augmenté puisque la croissance et donc
le pib étant plus important
statistiquement mais ça n'a aucun sens
ce qui a dû chances pour les français
c'est même pas tant leur pouvoir d'achat
réel que la perception qu'ils ont alors
faudra d'achat de leur pouvoir d'achat
contre 1 c'est à dire la part de pouvoir
d'achat ou concrètement à la fin du
moins il décide ça je peux faire ce que
je veux je peux juste obligé de payer
mon loyer payé la facture d'énergie ou
je sais pas quoi
et surtout il ya la perception du moment
historique dans lequel on vit et c'est
là où je pense qu'il peut toujours être
aller justement faire un parcours
historique
la semaine dernière il ne comprend pas
le moment historique que vivent un
certain nombre de français les déciles
fin les catégories les plus défavorisées
ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat baisser sur
les dix dernières années et ça n'a rien
à voir
dette pauvres ou dans une condition
défavorisés au début d'être un des
trente glorieuses quand vous vous
projeter dans un avenir
adieu que d'être à un moment où vous
vous dites non seulement je vis moins
bien aujourd'hui qu'il ya dix ans mais
j'anticipe que dans dix ans ça va être
pire est que pour mes enfants ce sera
pire encore et ça je pense qu'il ne
l'entend pas il y répond avec un
discours de techno et pardon mais on
parlait de sens je pense qu'il n'a pas
fait le service après vente du premier
ministre il sait condamné une forme
d'impasse sur son propre électorat sur
cette question des taxes qui est aussi
intéressant c'est le message que ça lui
permet de faire passer aux autres partis
politiques
et là ils interpellent les français on
vous m'ont dit il quasiment avec ces
mots écoutez moi j'entends la colère et
je pense c'est un droit fondamental dans
notre société de pouvoir l'exprimer
et donc nos concitoyens qui considère
qu'aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas entendus
pas considérer s'exprimer le dise
d'abord il faut le respecter
il faut l'entendre et ils ont tout à
fait le droit de manifester s'exprimer
ensuite je dis méfiance parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui veulent récupérer
ce mouvement
beaucoup de gens il ya beaucoup de
partis politiques la france insoumise
une partie des socialistes tous les
partis sauf le vôtre et les écologistes
oui c'est un bon résumé
mais je dis méfiance il ya beaucoup de
partis qui essaie de récupérer le
s'oppose à ce qu'ils vont voter eux
mêmes un pont pour lui là quand même sur
ce point car oui il renoue avec quelque
chose qui lui a vraiment réussi pendant
la campagne qui est de dire moi je suis
au cohérent moi je serai courageux je
tiendrai mes promesses ce j'irai
jusqu'au bout et regarde délai le tout
c'est en effet là dessus il arrive
englober à la fois tous les partis est à
la fois les élus locaux qui sont ses
principaux opposants dans les faits
depuis le début du quinquennat pour dire
'regardez ne sont pas cohérents moi je
suis cohérent et je vais jusqu'au bout
ils vous mentent ils vous manipulent oui
c'est là dessus que les français la peau
c'est pour cette raison que les français
ont voté pour la république en marche
qu'il n'existait pas un an auparavant et
ils l'utilisent parce qu'évidemment il
sent bien que c'est le ferment de ce
poujadisme le mot qu'il a eu l'idée à
deux reprises où jadis nos contemporains
exactement et il a parfaitement raison
historique - enfin c'est évidemment un
sac ça fait penser ça fait penser aussi
à des mouvements comme le tea party aux
états unis c'est à dire un mouvement
j'imagine que c'est ça qu'il craint
essayer parce que ce qu'on n'a pas dit
quand même c'est que cette campagne est
clair cette montée en ligue 2 tout le
monde à la fois du premier ministre à la
fois du président de la république qui
on le sait n'aime pas beaucoup avoir
tort et qui dit là j'ai échoué c'est
quand même une inquiétude très forte et
son attitude il la nomme son inquiétude
il dit j'ai peur du poujadisme c'est à
dire que ce ras-le-bol fiscales
auxquelles je ne peux pas répondre parce
que d'une certaine le justifie
oui il dit mais je vais pas d'aidé
baisser la dépense publique sur
l'éducation ni sur la défense nizon la
santé ni sur la
c'est quand même un peu une forme de
mépris pour les français parce que je
pense que tout le monde est capable de
concevoir que les impôts servent
évidemment à financer les hôpitaux les
policiers ou les écoles
enfin on voit aussi tous quand on a des
enfants à l'école qu'on va à l'hôpital
que malheureusement ce sont des envois
d'argent et que exactement et que par
ailleurs il ya un certain nombre de
secteurs ou à l'inversé à énormément de
gaspillage donc prétendre dire que ça
c'est de la pédagogie
parce qu'on pourrait lui dire mais si
l'objectif par ailleurs c'est juste la
transition écologique parce que voulait
être courageuse banane scala baisser les
taxes sur l'essence
et puis comme ça diesel et censure
joindre je finis juste mon raisonnement
il renoue avec quelque chose qui a très
bien marché c'est eux mentent ils sont à
cohérent et moi je suis courageux et
j'irai jusqu'au bout
sauf qu'en effet il avoue une forme
d'impuissance qui nous rappelle fatalité
les grandes heures de jeu star voire de
mitterrand qui dit ah mais quand je ne
peux pas baisser sa balle piquée sauf
contretemps 18 mois se sont passés si
vous voulez on voit bien que la
stratégie de communication qui est la
sienne sur le plan politique c'est de
ramener les oppositions à leurs
contradictions et finalement d'essayer
d'associer ce mouvement qui est un
mouvement qui quand même s'organise à
l'origine sur le terrain de banier assez
baasiste alors bien sûr il ya
l'information les formations peau
certaines formations politiques vont
soutenir certes mais quand même c'est un
mouvement qui de ce point de vue là à
une certaine forme de spontanéité même
qu'il faut se méfier de cette expression
spontanéité parce que tout est jeu tout
est toujours relative dans les
mobilisations mais ils essayent de
renvoyer finalement ce mouvement a une
certaine représentation politique qui
est celle de l'ancien monde et de
l'ancien monde qui a failli et de
l'ancien monde qui finalement est pétri
de contradictions
sauf que la vérité c'est que la
difficulté de ce mouvement c'est que
justement comme il n'appartient pas au
cadre de mobilisations classique que ce
soit qu'il s'agisse des syndicats ou des
partis politiques
il est totalement imprévisible et il
touche à quelque chose d'essentiel qui
fondamentalement relève quasiment de
l'inconscient mais avec une dose de 2,2
de côté très pratique c'est que
finalement vous c'est pas seulement le
pouvoir d'achat c'est la mobilité la
mobilité c'est la liberté aussi c'est là
les gens d'aller à leur travail dans des
zones où vous n'avez pas de transports
alternatifs donc il y à cette réalité
qui quand même aujourd'hui
ben elle excelle errements et on vient
la fiction c'est vrai qu'on écoute
quelques extraits de l'opposition
justement là où emmanuel macron renoue
également aux fondamentaux de la
campagne qui ont bien marché c'est quand
il fait des constats des constats qui
sont assez pertinent et sur lesquels en
fait il essaye de rassembler un maximum
quand il dit les français ont besoin de
considération de protection de sécurité
ce sont des choses sur lesquelles tout
le monde peut se reconnaître quand il va
également sur le terrain de l'unité
nationale il reprend la parole en
conclusion pour revenir sur ces sujets
là on retrouve les fondamentaux de la
campagne abolis si je trouve qu'il
change un petit peu parce que protection
souveraineté protéger celle des manques
il a ce sont des mots qui l'a répété
plusieurs fois il quittait pas aussi
présent il me semble que c'etait libéré
protéger et et unis de libérer une seule
écoute et ses représentants de
l'opposition tout au long de la soirée
notre journaliste à mme tran huy
interroge les sénateurs et sénatrices en
salle des conférences au sénat elle a
posé quelques questions à racheter mal
sénateur socialiste du val d'oise
écouter
rachid tu es mal autour de la colère des
gilet jaune est bien emmanuel macron n'a
pas été tendre avec les oppositions de
droite comme de gauche qui selon lui
récupère justement ce mouvement qu'en
pensez vous écoutez emmanuel macron est
dans une situation très compliquée
aujourd'hui le premier ministre a pris
la parole le président la pluie qu'a
pris la parole c'est une communication
de crise l'exécutif est perdu l'exécutif
est aux abois
alors ils essayent d'expliquer que c'est
de la faute des autres des revoyez bien
c'est toujours la faute des autres des
français qui comprennent pas des partis
politiques il sert et d'instrumentaliser
nous pour le parti socialiste nous
sommes dans aucune instrumentalisation
aucun ne regardons que des personnes qui
se battent pendant plus de services
publics sont à côté de personnes qui
réclament sommes moins de tact il dit
une addition de colère et de blocages ça
ne fait pas un projet le problème de
magnac rond c'est encore une fois les
dons privés encore dans une forme de
mensonge et même macron c'est celui qui
a donné plus de 10 milliards d'euros
chaque année aux plus riches
il prend 10 milliards d'euros budget
qu'il redonne via les cadeaux fiscaux et
il demande maintenant on reste du pays
de payer sa politique
c'est l'échec de l'apo tidermène macro
qui aujourd'hui a fait payer son projet
par les plus pauvres
pour faciliter ces le présent des plus
riches et donc je lui il est bloqué
alors qu'est ce qui nous dit il faut
payer encore plus mais ce n'est pas
possible mais la nacre on sait celui qui
baisse de pouvoir d'achat
d'ailleurs tous les français vous le
dise il perd du poids d'un chèque et
damien crouzat différentes manuellement
un maquereau s'en est défendu lors de
cette interview est ce que vous l'avez
vous je suppose que vous n'avez pas
trouvé convaincant il a dit qu'il
oeuvrait pour que les français gagnent
mieux leur vie et pour aussi et bien
faire baisser le coût par exemple en
négociant au niveau international le
prix du baril pour vous ce n'est pas
convaincant ce projet à écouter d'abord
il s'appuie sur les américains pour le
négoce et et juste avant explique trump
n'était pas très sûr premier pour un
deuxième point pour être un peu plus
sérieux
est ce que vous connaissez que les
retraités dans ce pays perdu point
d'achat les fonctionnaires perd du poids
d'achat ceux qui sont aux anneaux d
allocation d un père du foie d'achat on
voit bien on peut regarder comme sa
catégorie parts égales catégories les
français perdus point d'achat donc y'a
qu'emmanuel ma croquer dans une bulle
qui pensent que ces tableaux le permet
de surveiller ce qui se passe en france
la réalité c'est que les français
perdent du pouvoir d'achat ont moins
d'argent dans leurs dans l'europe pour
consommer et donc c'est néfaste à notre
économie
dernière question à ce que vous
mettez tout de même qu emmanuel macron a
entendu cette colère il l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises ça lui a servi cette
itinérance à la semaine dernière il a
entendu cette colère qu oui c'est
toujours lui en même temps il passe
toutes les missions explique qu'il ne
changera pas de politique et à la fin a
dit forget coup de plus d'ouvriers
encore une fois il ne change pas de
politique
ces deux présidents des plus riches et
l'addition et pour les français
bien merci beaucoup rajouté mal pour
votre merci y ont la meilleure défense
c'est l'attaqué
10 la meilleure défense est l'attaqué
moi c'est sur la forme de cette prise de
parole que je trouve ça c'est vraiment
la politique à l'ancienne on en voit
parce qu'on entend un discours très
formaté où on essaye jamais d'aller
tendre la main pour voir s'opposent pour
ça qu'on s'oppose pour s'opposer et
c'est vrai que ça c'est le prisme
société civile on sait ce que disent
beaucoup de français probablement ce
soir c'est vrai que c'est ça on s'oppose
pour s'opposer oui certainement mais le
la difficulté ce soir c'est qu'on voit
que finalement pour emmanuel macron le
problème se résout un problème d'image
c'est ce qui sait ce qu'il veut laisser
entendre c'est finalement en répétant
j'écoute j'entends je comprends il a dit
à plusieurs reprises durant cette
interview
finalement la question est d'abord un
problème d'image donc un problème de
communication politique
la vérité c'est que non ce n'est pas un
problème seulement d'imagés un problème
de communication politique et je vous
rejoins là dessus c'est un problème de
politique c'est un problème de politique
parce que finalement demain il décide de
renoncer aux hausses de taxes sur les
carburants
le mouvement des gilet jaune s'arrête du
jour au lendemain mais souvenez-vous eh
bien je vais prendre un exemple
historique celui de 86 86
au moment des manifestations étudiantes
contre le projet de loi devaquet sur
l'autonomie des universités le
gouvernement de jacques chirac et
jacques chirac avait décidé du jour au
lendemain après notamment les
manifestations qui avaient conduit au
décès de malik oussékine 2
retirer le projet et la mobilisation
s'était éteinte dans l'âme il n'avait
pas empêché non mais ça n'avait pas
empêché
d'abord il faut arrêter de dire vous
savez ça n'avait pas empêché le
gouvernement d'ailleurs de cohabitation
de jacques chirac en transe 86 et 88 de
mener un certain nombre de réformes
importantes
c'est un des gouvernements qui à droite
avait mené certainement le plus grand
nombre de réformes de ces trente
dernières années il avait reculé sur
cette disposition
on peut penser aussi qu'il ya peut-être
parfois matière à capitaliser sur un
retrait afin tout simplement de montrer
par des gestes que l'on est capable d'en
temps parce que si vous voulez montrer
que vous êtes capables il faut des
gestes non mais effectivement je
comprends ce qui est dit on s'en
souvient plus récemment avec les bonnets
rouges aussi une fois que l'écotaxe a
été retiré le mouvement s'est
relativement essoufflé alors même que
certains des leaders des bund et bonnets
rouges avaient eu des ambitions
politiques
pourtant je pense quand même accro à un
problème politique qui dépasse de très
loin la mobilisation des gilets jaunes
c'est à dire que là les français se
reconnaissent dans cette revendication
là mais c'est ce que je vais faire
l'essence n'est jamais que la
cristallisation donc ça lui permettrait
peut-être mais je pense qui
s'affaiblirait sur son propre électorat
à ce que je disais c'est un peu
l'équation impossible
et puis surtout sa crainte est que son
propre électorat justement renonce à le
soutenir lui en disant mais finalement
il n'est pas aussi au niveau des caisses
que ce qui nous avait promis est
précisément que une évaporation vers les
écologistes ont qu'il n'a que des
mauvais choix en quelque sorte il n'a
que des mauvais choix justement
l'halloween arrive à transcender sa
reconnaissance des chèques en creux
c'est quoi c'est la république en marche
n'a pas réussi à être ciudadanos ou
podemos c'est à dire on a vu
l'effondrement des corps traditionnel
français que ce soit les partis
politiques où que ce soit les syndicats
il ya eu un énorme espoir réel dans le
pays au moment de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron et bien cet espoir là il est mort
la république en marche n'est pas devenu
un mouvement citoyen année porteuse de
rien du tout malheureusement à l'heure
actuelle on le voit avec l'élection qui
se joue pour en désigner le secrétaire
général il n'y a aucune discussion
politique carole initiale je ne suis pas
d'accord au sens où je pense que ce
serait probablement repoussé
le moment de l'explosion parce que si on
écoute vraiment précisément les français
enfin les gilet jaune
qu'est-ce qui me disent on ne vit pas
bien s'abaisseront baisserait les sens
ça serait peut-être mieux mais ça ne
résoudrait pas tous les problèmes que
cela deuxièmement ils disent on nous
prend pour des imbéciles parce qu'on
nous enlève d'un côté ce qu'on nous
reprend de l'autre on nous a certes
enlever la taxe d'habitation mais on
nous le reprend par les sens et ça c'est
quand même un des fondements de la
politique d' en marche depuis le début
qui est un petit peu du dosage
troisième question qui est posée là
j'utilise les mots que j'ai entendu
qu'elle est c'est les mots qu'il est
qu'est-ce qu'il fait qu'est ce qu'ils
font de notre pognon et ça ça vient
questionner de cette manière là les
filles alice l'efficacité de la
politique publique donc même si cette
désordonnée et pas du tout coordonné par
les corps intermédiaires politiques et
syndicats que macron à dézinguer avec
beaucoup d'efficacité
il ya des questions de fond vraiment
importante est vraiment pertinente qui
sont posées l'autre thème majeur sur
lequel il est intéressant de s'arrêter
ce soir c'est celui de la relation avec
donald trump est avec les etats unis en
général il a eu ses phrases très forte
est rallié ce n'est pas être le vassal
être alliés ont entre alliés pardon on
se doit le respect l'occasion pour lui
de revenir sur cette idée d'armée
européenne et donc de souveraineté
nationale écoutez je veux que nous
soyons autonomes en matière d' écoute en
matière de protection du cyberespace et
contre les attaques cyber et puis sur
toutes les composantes de nos armées sur
terre sur mer
par voie aérienne et dans l'espace et
donc pour ce faire nous ne devons pas
dépendre y compris des états unis et sur
certaines sur certains domaines
parfois nous avons trop des pendus et ça
n'était pas bon et vous allez me dire
dans un instant ce que vous en pensez
mais on continue de faire le tour des
réactions côté sénateurs tam tran huy a
pu interroger le sénateur l ère de la
meuse gérard longuet gérard ont dit qu
avez vous pensé de cette phrase
d'emmanuel macron être allié ce n'est
pas d'être le vassal c'est finalement ce
qu'il a répondu aux attaques de donald
trump sur twitter est ce que d'une part
cette phrase est juste et d'autre part à
ce que cette réponse est suffisante
satisfaisante face au président
américain lors cessé complètement la
tradition française nous sommes les
alliés des etats-unis depuis l'origine
en revanche nous ne sommes pas
dépendants d'eux et d'ailleurs nous
avons eu des divergences sur toute une
série de sujets général de gaulle est là
pour me rappeler à travers ses prises de
position alors en revanche est ce qu'ils
lisent ans quand on se fait attaquer
ainsi alors bon le la personnalité trump
ce ne sont pas des états unis faut il
faut distinguer un président qui a une
singularité un profil particulier et je
pense que le président élu et française
n'a pas à intervenir sur le registre
très singulier très spécifique très
spécial est un peu dérangeant de
monsieur crème en revanche je crois
qu'il ya une vraie question c'est ce que
l'europe est capable de se défendre par
elle-même et at elle besoin absolument
des états unis je pense que l'europe
devrait avoir beaucoup plus confiance en
elle et que de nombreux pays européens
acceptent l'idée qu'ils n'ont pas besoin
que des états unis qu'ils ont besoin
d'eux et est-ce que donc l'europe a
besoin d'une armée européenne
c'est une autre chose à une armée une
armée sanaa ça n'a pas de sens s'il n'ya
pas une volonté politique
le fond du problème européen en ce qui
concerne la défense c'est qu'il faudrait
une règle de majorité très strictes pour
pouvoir prendre des décisions en nous en
sommes extraordinairement loin imaginons
une seule difficulté que ce soit dans un
pays balte où que ce soit face à la
turquie ou face
à toutes sortes de menaces sommes-nous
certains d'avoir une majorité européenne
la réponse est non et une armée c'est un
outil mais c'est un outil au service
d'un projet politique
enfin emmanuel macron a également et
bien de répéter que sa programmation
militaire était très satisfaisante en
expansion la première depuis la guerre
froide il a était également intervenue
et bien sûr franchement son budget n'est
pas mauvais mais ils exagèrent un peu et
exagère un peu parce que d'une part
l'essentiel de l'effort est quand même
en fin de quinquennat voir après le
quinquennat articles 1 et dès cette
année avec le financement des obsèques
ce qui porte essentiellement et
inutilement sur le budget de la défense
on n'est pas certain d'avoir tout lé
toutes les sommes prévues pour
entretenir notre armée donc emmanuel
macron pas complètement convaincant pour
vous là dessus non on met un petit peu
un peu limite toi un peu limite bon vin
il est quand même dans son rôle et pour
sur le porte-avions avec nos rafale je
t'ai donné une belle image
merci beaucoup gérard longuet pour votre
réaction c'est intéressant parce que
pour un sénateur a l'air il n'est pas si
sévère que cela avec emmanuel macron
alexeï guerman sur ces prisonniers du
fond il ya beaucoup de fond c'est ça qui
est très intéressant d'abord sur
l'interview elle même je crois que
c'était la partie la plus intéressante
la plus dense d'ailleurs que l'on ait
eue avec le mea culpa mais la fin donc
en fait on a une inteview très cadré
excellent au début excellent à la fin
avec
je crois qu'il a eu raison d'ailleurs de
ne pas intervenir plus que cela sur
l'inélégance des tweets de donald trump
il est sur une position diplomatique
bien affirmée et il a très bien enchaîné
sur l' armée une armée européenne le
lien la souveraineté nationale le
patriotisme européen et le lien avec
angela merkel qui venait en soutien
peut-être un bémol en revanche parce que
là effectivement ce que fait le sénateur
longuet il est vrai que quand il est
allé en plein milieu de ces
commémorations parler de l'armée
européenne de deux remarques là-dessus
la première chose c'est que ce n'était
pas forcément contre mais on aurait pu
le préciser dans la formulation être à
peut-être un peu plus rond en précisant
que c'était quelque chose qui pouvait
accompagner à ce moment là l'armée
américaine est pas forcément mettre sur
le même plan premiers points 2e pour moi
sur l'armée européenne
il est clair que on n'est plus
aujourd'hui sur des coopérations
bilatérales qui peuvent se faire donc
c'est quand même jeté un pavé dans la
mare au moment de commémoration d'aller
en quelque sorte un peu énervé les uns
et les autres sur un sujet qui de toute
façon n'est pas n'est pas réalisable
aujourd'hui
et puis quand même macron aime bien les
chiffres mais la curieuse mans ils les
oublient pas ce que moi j'adorerais
convives dans un univers où il a une
vraie armée européenne pour reprendre
l'expression puisse exister enfin gérard
longuet 10 elle a souligné de manière
très feutrée enfin la réalité c'est que
ça n'est pas possible il n'ya pas de
souveraineté européenne
en l'état il n'y a pas de diagnostic sur
les menaces qui nous entoure a pas de
diagnostic commun n'y a pas de volonté
comme oui comment on bien sûr tout est
dans le coma ciation d'accord et dans le
tout est dans le coma et quand même
juste les chiffres il se trouve que le
total des dépenses militaires cumulé
l'union européenne ça représente
péniblement le tiers des dépenses
militaires des états unis donc en donald
trump dit baye quand même une alliance
qui s'appelle l'otan qui vous a quand
même pas mal servi parce que je veux
bien que la réconciliation franco
allemande
effectivement et permis la paix en
europe il me semble que la présence des
chars américains et la présence des
tanks soviétiques ça aussi contribué à
cette histoire là donc je trouve qu'il
ya quelque chose de complètement
chimérique dans ses propos là et encore
plus le jour où moi j'ai entendu la
candidate
enfin une des candidates et figurez-vous
la modérer annette
anne grete pardon quand karine beauvoir
une des candidats donc à la succession
d'angela merkel d'hier à bah oui mais
faudra encore le courage de dire à la
france que avec moi ça sera l'allemagne
en premier set nerfs elle s'inspire d'un
vocabulaire totalement entretien donc je
veux bien qu emmanuel macron nous
explique tout ce qu'il veut sur l'europe
moi j'aimerais beaucoup parce que je
crois à l'europe mais malheureusement ça
n'est pas le contexte dans lequel nous
vivons tous cas je sais pas si l'alarmé
parce que c'est quand même un peu par
cet hymne aussi parler france mais ça a
été malin de répondre à trump sans
vraiment lui répondre en glissant
derrière mais robben et en parlant
souveraineté politiquement c'est plutôt
malin
c'était certainement le meilleur passage
de l'ensemble de l'entretien parce que
il était dans la pondération par rapport
à un train qui évidemment excessif donc
de ce point de vue là il avait tout à
gagner il a rappelé la relation
historique de la france et des états
unis donc de ce point de vue là c'était
très bien parce qu'il dépersonnaliser le
débat le problème c'est que ça paraît un
peu hors sujet au regard du contexte si
vous voulez parce que là l'urgence de la
communication aujourd'hui dans le moment
ce n'est pas tellement l'armée
européenne c'est la conjoncture
politique à laquelle il est il est
soumis donc alors après sur la question
des armées européennes robles qui a
derrière en fait
emmanuel macron a voulu réhabiliter
l'idée que le politique pouvait
redevenir souverain et disposer d'une
puissance d'action
là où on considère que finalement le
politique mais il n'est plus capable de
maîtriser good ce soir donc il s'adresse
à un certain public en parlant de
souveraineté ce sont les mots pardon
mais des extraits mais en tout cas de
demain et le problème c'est que c'est
trop subtil et sans subir que ça soit un
moment donné véritablement perçu
donc le problème de la souveraineté
d'abord c'est celui de la souveraineté
économique aussi c'est ça qui qui qui
pose problème qui pose question pourquoi
certain nombre de gens justement qui
vont manifester samedi qu'ils vont
bloquer les routes c'est plutôt cette
question qui laissait la question
sociale la question économique qui
démobilise la question la question de la
défense qui est absolument essentiel
bien évidemment pour la france et pour
l'europe
c'est une question qui est perçu comme
quand même relativement lointaine regard
du contexte
mais pas ne pas l'aborder car les michel
je vais prendre votre rôle de minutes us
sur la communication on l'a pas dit
encore parce que c'était une évidence
mais je le pose là toute cette mise en
scène
et oui oui mais quand même raison blier
non avérés vains scène des deux hommes
avec les rafales sur le porte-avions et
cetera et cetera font des appels du pied
très très fort à tous que la france a
gaullien et c'est pour ça que je fais un
lien il s'agit de représailles présente
dacia lisez la compagnie d'un demi voilà
fonctions régaliennes à défense donc le
printemps voit bien comment tout ça a
été pensée jeu axial de guerre mais oui
c'est ça alors le matin le pré le
premier ministre est allé lui sur les
radios dire comment on va faire un
et puis là on a le président voilà très
très le l'image est très belle en ahl el
le le drapeau français le drapeau
européen et galien exactement et caisses
de quoi il vient nous parler il vient
nous parler de ce qu'ils préparent pour
les futures élections européennes ce
thème de souveraineté qu'il n'est pas le
souverainisme de marée peine et on a
bien vu dans l'inflexion des dernières
semaines que la thématique qui
l'utilisent
par ailleurs après dont on a dit qu'elle
était moins pertinente
les progressistes contrôler nationaliste
il a bien compris que ça commence à être
un peu basique avec ça n'avait pas
marché donc il en dose quelque chose à
la fois ce pro europe et à nice mme qui
était sa particularité depuis le début
qu'il n'abandonne pas et en même temps
il va beaucoup plus loin dans la
revendication de la souveraineté aux
rémois l'air mais c'est surtout qui
vient en prendre un cheval de bataille
qu'il n'était pas le sien on voit
vraiment que quand il vient de parler de
deck sans cesse d'armer européenne lui
qui est un foncièrement un libéral qui
pour l'ouverture etc
il vient prendre quelque chose qui
correspond à une image qui va avec
l'image jeu peut-être il est bon mais je
ne sais pas s'il est né vous l'avez pris
sur le terrain
l'avait prise sur le terrain de la com
et vous avez raison parce que c'est pas
là son seul championnat car et c'est
parce que il n'est pas en train
réellement parler de souveraineté
européenne parce qu'il y aurait quand
même bien d'autres choses en dire à
l'heure actuelle a émis tong aurait pu
aussi parler de l'accord ou du nom
d'accords sur le brésil
mais de la même manière que les
consommer non mais je viens on peut se
mettre devant des rafales autant qu'on
veut on peut se mettre en scène avec les
français en faisant des itinérances
mémorielle ou à clé de chez pas quel
gadget le prochain dispositif de com qui
sera imaginé mais de la même manière que
dans les supermarchés aujourd'hui il ya
ces applications qui vous permet de le
marque l'emballage peut être parfait le
packaging peut être génial vous donné
très envie d'acheter
mais sauf qu'il ya une application qui
vous disent qu'il ya exactement dans le
produit est bien là c'est comme si les
gens qui gérait la communication
politique à l'e10 est à l'heure actuelle
mais c'est valable au delà de l'elysée
considéré que les français finalement
était pas capable dans cet espèce de
traducteurs automatiques et que il
regarde cette image
ça me rappelle le général de gaulle non
mais franchement il ya un effet un peu
ravageur à cette dénégation là c'est à
dire que non seulement ça ne produit pas
l'effet recherché
mais en plus ça a un petit côté je vous
prends un peu pour dénier sur l'europe
je crois qu'on voit bien que depuis une
semaine à peu près il a basculé sur
cette notion de patriotisme européen qui
n'a rien à voir qui n'est pas au
détriment du patriotisme national et
c'est une nouvelle idée qu'il commence à
souffler dans la campagne
voyons que progressiste contre nationale
y est sorti le plus crédible ça va être
compliqué parce qu'il a vraiment à
quelque chose mais il entame quelque
chose mais encore faut-il qu'il y ait
quelqu'un en face enfin on peut parce
que c'est quand le grand paradoxe de
dire je ne suis pas nationaliste mais
finalement j'ai un projet pour l'europe
qui est tellement français que c'est une
forme de projet si ce n'est nationaliste
du moins nationale parce que c'est quand
même comme ça que c'est vécu ailleurs en
europe
oui mais ces difficultés là elle risque
à un moment la campagne des européennes
elle se fera aussi avec justement les
interactions qui sont en train de se
créer entre d'autres partis d'autres
mouvements à commencer par les
mouvements copie g il ya sept autres
séquences intéressantes dont vous avez
déjà parlé alexia germans on va y
revenir c'est la fin c'est une interview
lorsqu'il fait effectivement cette sorte
de mea culpa et
et inédit il revient sur l'un de ses
échecs sur ce qui le touche profondément
écouter ya de l'impatience milliers de
la colère et cette colère je la partage
passe quelque chose que je n'ai pas
vraiment réussi à faire
c'est je n'ai pas réussi à réconcilier
le peuple français avec ses dirigeants
et ça c'est vrai
et ça me touche moi mais si ça me
touchait que ma personne à la rigueur ce
ne serait pas grave
mais c'est plus profond et ce divorce on
le voit dans toutes les démocraties
occidentales
il m'inquiète et je considère qu'il est
au coeur de la mission qui est
aujourd'hui la mienne est là aussi
finalement il parle d'europe arnaud
benedetti c'est un mot très fort le mot
divorce
oui mais c'est vrai qu'on voit bien
qu'il y avait une baseline qui a dû être
travaillés vraisemblement par ses
communicants pour que tout le monde
lance une baseline c'est-à-dire un
slogan je veux dire qui va un moment
donné en sortir et qui va être repris
par tous les commentateurs et d'ailleurs
s'ils croient tous les commentateurs
c'est vraiment ce qu'on retient
aujourd'hui essentiellement de
l'entretien des manuels macro moi je
pense que oui c'est pas l'essentiel mais
ce qui est important dans cette affaire
c'est que il dit que l'ensemble des
démocraties occidentales sont tout
simplement touché par ce syndrome
c'est pas tout à fait vrai d'ailleurs il
ya des démocraties où aujourd'hui vous
avez des gouvernements qui ont un
assentiment massif de leurs populations
ce sont notamment les gouvernements
qu'ils qualifient de populiste qui eux
bénéficient notamment en italie
aujourd'hui d'une adhésion pour
l'instant en tout cas qui est massive
donc vous voyez bien que quelque part
aussi son son discours est il réel et il
est d'une certaine manière réducteur
mais le problème c'est qu'encore une
fois il donne le sentiment que
finalement c'est sa communication et ses
sons images qui aujourd'hui font qu' il
y à ce divorce entre les dirigeants et
les peuples et l'opinion la réalité
encore une fois c'est que le problème
est d'abord politique et la
communication arrive après parce que en
fait c'est bien ça aujourd'hui la
difficulté à laquelle il est confronté
oui moi j'ai pas tout à fait la même
analyse il me semble que là où la prise
de parole et fine c'est que justement il
ne répond pas sur son arrogance
personnel on a l'impression qu'il prend
la mesure en fait de la responsabilité
qu'ils ont en ayant pris le pouvoir en
en saccageant l'ensemble des partis
politiques et en disant on va vous
donner une offre qu'on nouvelle or
l'offre nouvelle a du mal à prendre
racine
c'est ça la vraie responsabilité et
c'est très grave parce que si on se
retrouve en bout de course avec plus de
structure politique même s'il y avait
beaucoup de chose qui n'allait pas mais
des structures politiques qui sont
complètement éclatés d'une part une un
parti qui était censé être un peu plus
transversal qui n'arrive pas à prendre
corps dans une europe qui est quand même
très mouvementée en ce moment ce sera
vraiment un champ de bataille sans rien
derrière et j'ai l'impression mois plus
tôt qui là qu'il a compris ça ben oui
enfin il l'a compris il a compris de
manière un peu mécanique je sais pas
s'il l'a compris sentiment qu'il avait
réalisé quelque chose ça n'a pas été un
moment où vous ai dit on a besoin qu'il
a senti la macro sommes parfaitement
enfin très intelligent dans une bulle
déconnecté peut être il est quand même
capable de lire une enquête d'opinion il
est quand même capable se rendent compte
que même quand ils se déplacent dans des
endroits où on a pris grand soin
d'écarter tous les gens qui de près ou
de loin aurait pu ressembler à des gilet
jaune donc circuler quand même déjà dans
mais les gens qui s'adressent à lui il
ya déjà une sélection il faut le
rappeler quand même mais c'est normal
aussi des services de sécurité du
président pourrait pas laisser la colère
prendre donc c'est je ne sais pas juste
la communication c'est aussi une
nécessité
donc évidemment qu'il a compris mais at
il compris ce que ressent profondément
les gens je ne crois pas je ne crois pas
qu'ils soient conscients de cette
inquiétude civilisationnel et c'est
réparé très particulier parce que c'est
ça qui est paradoxal avec emmanuel
macron c'est qu'il alterne entre le
discours très technocratique
le discours de je regarde un tableur
excel et je fais des moyennes et
finalement regardé la moyenne est bonne
oui mais comme je le dis dans la sarthe
32 kg les pieds dans le frigo la tête
dans le four
si je suis dans le four je veux bien que
tu m'expliques ma température moyenne
est bonne mais j'ai quand même très
chaud oui mais c'est un peu ça son
problème c'est un peu ça quand même son
problème son problème politique à
l'image mais parce que parce que c'est
le raisonnement technocrates et à
d'autres moments et c'est ça que je
trouve perturbons chez lui à d'autres
moments de l'année dernière son
interview de rentrée dans le point il
disait je suis le dernier des mohicans
nous sommes peut-être à la fin d'une
civilisation et c'est très bizarre parce
qu'il est constamment dans cette espèce
de six nations entre parce que parfois
il met en cause les populismes et pour
le lendemain dire quelque chose qui
finalement n'est pas si éloigné sur
l'immigration sur le destin de l'europe
pas si éloigné de ce qu aurait pu dire
un viktor orban et à l'arrivée on est un
peu perdu sur que veut emmanuel macron
mais le sait-il enfin quand je dis ça
c'est que je crois pas du tout qu'il
soit lui promet c'est simplement je
pense qu'il n'est pas il ya un point de
maturité ça aller très très vite pour
lui ça allait très vite aussi au sein de
la société française
la république en mal à d'idéologie de
maturité mais au sens de maturation au
sens un projet politique un projet
politique où il ya des ingrédients qui
sont présents il ya des intuitions il ya
une espèce d'intuition parfois abri
street et de maturation peut-être pour
parler plus justement que de maturité
meubles on n'est pas arrivés au terme de
cette maturation la remise en cause même
si on n'a pas envie de dire que c'est du
cinéma
je pense que la remise en cause a n'est
pas profonde elle est un peu
superficielle à cause de ces raisons là
c'est un jeune homme qui n'a pas
l'habitude de se tromper qu'il n'a pas
l'habitude des choix qu'il n'a pas
l'habitude d'opter de ne pas obtenir ce
qu'ils veulent qui n'a pas l'habitude de
ne pas séduire
il n'est pas habitué à l'adversité et à
cette remise en cause profonde parfois
douloureuses et qui va aller chercher
fin qu'on connaît tous ce qui va les
chercher ailleurs dans d'autres choses
de quoi se nourrir d'aller à l'étape
d'après et je trouve qu'au moment où il
dit ça dans son regard
on sent quelque chose d'un petit peu
quand même c'est bizarre je vais jouer
alors je pense ça que je réussirai le
premier de la glace j'ai à tout d'un
coup je ne suis pas sûr pour le dire
autrement mais la même chose que ce que
vous venez de dire qu'il soit totalement
outillés par l'expérience par la vie
pour répondre à ce questionnement
profond qui est peut-être
ce qu'ils croyaient d'une manière un peu
naïve ou peut-être simpliste être la
seule réforme dont il a parlé c'est
absolument incroyable c'est là je veux
dire c'était important ok c'était
important mais s'il pense vraiment que
c'est en changeant la sncf qui va
changer avec un canard mais oui non pas
du tout et il a dit quand même un moment
quelque chose qui m'a frappé qui me
paraissait être un énorme mensonge
il a dit on fait une politique
industrielle on va re transformation en
cassation
et alors là excusez moi je tombe de ma
chaise parce que s'il ya bien une chose
qui est l'angle mort absolu de la
politique d' emmanuel macron c'est la
politique industrielle
donc là il nous embobine un peu il a
comme un champ de conscience qui se dit
quand même la politique industrielle ça
m'ennuie je préfère les start up mais au
fond du fond joran de l'est et ce qui
leur manque c'est des usines avec des
ouvriers
mais ce n'est pas outillée ce n'est pas
profond quoi rien autre angle mort c'est
la culture démocratique parce que il
faut jamais oublier que emmanuel macron
s'est vendu comme langue qui allait
renouveler les pratiques politiques et
notamment qu'il aurait malgré tout une
démarche très participative beaucoup
plus démocratique que celle des vieux
partis
et qu'est ce qu'il a construit autour de
lui il a construit un parti politique
qui est monocéphale qui est monolithique
ou certes on ne tombe pas dans les
travers de ce qu'avait pu être le parti
socialiste avec les courants nous
finalement il n'y a qu'une tête qui
dépasse et où il n'ya surtout aucun
relais pour incarner le maquereau nisme
parce que finalement moi ce qui me
frappe aujourd'hui à travers le
notamment ces images c'est que macro est
un homme très seul
c'est un homme très seul il est il et il
est en permanence dans une entreprise de
surexposition pour défendre sa politique
il a finalement assez peu de relais
autour de lui si ce n'est un premier
ministre qui fait assez bien le job et
qui pour le moins je dirais est capable
d'aller à un moment donné défendre la
politique qui fait qu'un très bon soldat
la difficulté c'est qu'il ya une
contradiction initial entre la promesse
de macron qui était encore une fois
celle de renouveler les pratiques
politiques et la réalité c'est qu'on a
un parti politique qui est extrêmement
monolithique extrêmement verticale qui
rappellent finalement quasiment lui dr
et encore je suis même pas sûr des
années
année 210 ou les années 60 et de ce
point de vue là deux choses pour aller
pour aller dans votre sens si on le
compare à donald trump à ce que disent
ils est très seul mais donald trump est
partie justement en étant assez seul il
s'est imposé au parti républicain mais
quand même à la barbe de tous les
leaders du parti
mais là les élections de mi-mandat ont
montré que le parti républicain il avait
nettoyé de tous ceux qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec lui et en revanche il y a
des trucs
il a fini par être homme qui serait
d'être en piste en quelque sorte c'est à
dire que on peut critiquer donald trump
sa manière de faire des choses qui est
effectivement incroyablement beau
brutale dans un certain nombre de cas
vulgaire inculte on peut y ajouter tous
les qualificatifs gouvernement mais
réellement il ya des résultats sauf
qu'il ya des résultats et que même temps
le regarda sa et deuxième chose qui va
aussi dans le sens de ce que vous disiez
on avait fait des enquêtes on a été les
premiers ils ont été reprises ensuite
mais sur atlantico il ya déjà trois ou
quatre ans maintenant à tester justement
l'appétence des français pour la
démocratie et ont testé deux questions
il y avait la question de l'adhésion à
l'idée d'un régime autoritaire
même au prix de certaines libertés
publiques il y avait déjà plus de 45%
des français qui répondait oui ça a été
refait je crois par le cevipof récemment
et nous on avait un deuxième thème qui
était sûr y est vous en faveur d'un
gouvernement d'experts non élus et bien
vous savez on la refait depuis élections
des manades macron et c'est assez
révélateur parce que l'appétence pour le
régime autoritaire a n'a pas baissé en
revanche elle pour le gouvernement
d'experts manet vue elle l a beaucoup d
beaucoup baissé un peu comme si
finalement les français avaient essayé
pour voir et puis le résultat n'était
pas la marche pas malheureusement le
chemin qui reste un peu c'est cet espace
2 tentation quand même large pour un
régime autoritaire et encore une fois je
trouve que la mise en scène donald trump
qui peut twitté autant qu'il veut il ya
des institutions solides aux états unis
il ya quand même un congrès il ya une
cour suprême fin juin il n'est pas le
seul à prendre des décisions aux etats
unis quand vous avez le pouvoir en
france à l'elysée vous pouvez prendre
quasiment toutes les décisions que vous
voulez sauf que jouer sur jouer la
démocratie directe en vous mettant en
permanence face aux français hélas cette
espèce de succession
moment de qom et ces moments de
rencontre avec les français mais
souligne en creux justement le fait ce
que je me disais tout à l'heure la
république en marche ce n'est pas un sou
danos ça n'est pas un peu des mots ça
n'est pas un nouveau parti de man le
général de gaulle se méfiait du régime
des partis mais ne se méfier pas des
partis il en avait quand même créé un et
là il ya quand même une urgence
démocratique à ce que derrière emmanuel
macron les gens qui l'ont porté soutenu
s'empare de ça sauf que quand on regarde
l'élection la décharge il s'agissait de
voir la différence entre le maquereau
nice mais le gaullisme c'est que le
gaullisme avait des bases populaires des
base sociologique populaire c'est comme
le bonapartisme d'ailleurs dans
l'histoire de france
vous avez des mouvements qui sont des
mouvements des grains de synthèse comme
ça mais qui s'appuie sur des bases
populaires le point de vue macro nisme
sait que sa base sociologique est
extrêmement restreinte et c'est ce qu'il
est c'est cette prise de conscience là
moi je crois qu'on l'envoyait ce soir en
toile de fond quel noir alors on va
poursuivre notre tour d'horizon des
réactions côté senna et on va écouter
esther benbassa toujours interrogé par
tam tran huy esther benbassa sénatrice
europe ecologie les verts
esther benbassa qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de cette partition des rôles avec
d'une part les annonces très concrète le
matin du premier ministre et puis
emmanuel macron qui tente de prendre de
la hauteur depuis le porte-avions le
charles-de-gaulle et qu'ils commencent
par le domaine réservé du président de
la république la politique étrangère
écoutez comme d'habitude il y avait
beaucoup de mises en scène enfin ce
porte-avions puis c'est pour quand même
se donner
n'est ce pas cette stature de l'homme
qui domine l'avion jupiter les airs
n'est ce pas c'est c'était assez
intéressant
et contrairement à ce qu'il a pu dire
parce que c'était un peu moins
intéressant
puis moi je veux accompli du tout vous
quand il a commencé avec étreintes les
tweets est idéal qui n'a pas voulu
répondre aux tweets
bon ben on vous l'avait regretté qu'il
ne réponde pas ce grand sujet de
position autrement autrement nous avons
été tous ensemble depuis début première
guerre mondiale deuxième guerre mondiale
et puis les les tours bon écoute et les
tours de france et historienne qui parle
la hausse la wii u là c'était un peu de
l'art du récit
[Musique]
pour occuper l'espace et j'ai été très
étonné
et en même temps tel qu'on le connaît
mais moi je le connais pas
personnellement mais tel qu'on le
connaît depuis son accession au pouvoir
et le fait de ne pas laisser parler le
journaliste c'était étonnant dans un
pays des libertés individuelles de la
dollée la liberté d'expression c'est
c'est quand même ça interpelle quand
même et pourtant emmanuel macron a dit
être à l'écouté l écoute de la colère du
peuple il ya eu comme des nouveaux mots
là-dessus où il dit est bien respectée a
dit qu'il fallait avoir plus de
considération pour le peuple qu'est ce
que vous en avez pensé d'abord le mot
considérations ne m'a pas du tout plu
c'était quand même un peu il parlait
comme ça dans au voile a de la
considération
lambin il n'a pas seulement avoir de la
considération il faut qu'il communique
avec le peuple
c'est ça le problème est là de nouveau
il s'est montré au dessus du peuple il
le protège bon écoutez je ne crois pas
que il a pu renouer avec le puck sur toi
avec tout ce qu'il a dit un mot à propos
de cette parole qui l'a vu propos de la
sphère benalla j'ai peut-être commis une
erreur mon tour en d'untel ou d'untel un
début de mea culpa ce que vous y êtes
sensibles sensible je ne sais pas mais
enfin c'était cet appel benalla qui n'a
fait pas très importante
il en a fait une vraie affaire parce
qu'il n'a pas été assez politique et il
n'a pas su se débarrasser d'eux les
débuts il l'a protégé
mais parce que c'est le chevalier la
loyauté la fidélité bon écouter un mea
culpa qui donc ne vous a pas convaincu
merci beaucoup c'est m'a pas beaucoup
touché surtout merci beaucoup
il n'a pas pu renouer avec le peuple dit
esther benbassa il vous reste une minute
chacun pour nous dire si oui ou non il a
esquissé un début de réconciliation avec
les français ce soit caroline michel
aguer moi je serais plus négatif que ce
que je l'étais au début non non non mais
pour être sincère je trouve qu'au final
qu'est ce qu'on se dit contrairement à
ce que vous disiez je trouve qu'elle
doit philippe par deux fois a montré à
quel point il n'avait pas senti courant
arrivée populaire sur les 80 kilomètres
heure qui restera au delà de la sphère
benalla qui restera une coupure profonde
je pense maintenant sur l'essence ça
fait deux fois qu'il doive philippe ne
sent pas le coup ne sent pas la colère
et réagit au dernier moment donc je
trouve que de ce point de vue là mc on
n'est pas aidés on va disons que je n'ai
pas envie de les désolidariser mais de
fait qu'il ne sent pas les coups et
c'est plutôt à edouard philippe de
laisse entière est par ailleurs sur le
fond mais c'est ce qu'on vient de dire
on n'est pas rassurés on sent une
angoisse on comprendre les grands enjeux
on les partage on ne voit pas la réponse
alain benedetti il est plus anxiogène
que rassurant aujourd'hui je trouve sa
relation avec le premier ministre est
compliqué parce que tout simplement
aujourd'hui le la réduction du mandat
cinq ans fait que finalement le premier
ministre ni plus un protecteur pour le
président de la république ce qu'il
était sous le septennat et ça c'est une
réalité
ensuite le problème c'est que on lui
reproche à la fois de faire trop de
communication ça c'est évident vous
écoutez les propos de la sénatrice mais
on lui reproche aussi de ne pas assez
communiqué en direction du peuple donc
il est dans une espèce de contradiction
le canal est aussi extrêmement qui est
extrêmement difficile ensuite on voit
bien on va voir comment la situation va
évoluer sur le terrain dans les jours
qui viennent
et ça sera là qu'on aura véritablement
le juge de paix qui nous permettra de
dire si quelque part l'exercice a
commencé à redresser l'image avec une
première réponse dès samedi alex à
gerland pour une parole présidentielle
qui devait être rares s'habitue
finalement
le voir relativement fréquemment et
c'est peut-être là cellulaire dans
l'interview
c'est peut-être aussi une erreur en tout
cas il est vrai qu on a grillé
aujourd'hui deux cartouches en même
temps alors que le premier ministre
aurait pu faire le service après vente
qui était nécessaire on a quand même une
succession de mises en perspectives de
mises en situation très solennelle avec
toute la séquence de commémoration plus
ce soir sur le porte-avions qui est
peut-être finalement plus brouillonne en
bout de course
en revanche je suis reçu la forme de la
prise de parole
j'ai trouvé qu'il avait su rebondir
quand même à certains moments très très
justement jean sébastien ferjou une
intervention inefficace pour reconquérir
l'opinion reconquérir le coeur des
français
je pense peut-être ça peut consolider
son coeur des lectorats y avait une
forme d'émiettement mais ça reste quand
même quelque chose qui est très en
défensive si on avait un emmanuel macron
qui nous avait habitués à marcher sur
l'eau en tout cas au moins pendant sa
campagne présidentielle
là il se refait plus sur les vagues il
est un peu poussé justement par l'eau
par l'eau derrière lui moi je trouve que
cette espèce de mélange systématique des
registres qu'on a vu la semaine dernière
avec le mélange du rgi de la
commémoration parler à la fois d'ascq
ovale et de 1918 et gharbi riz qu'on
peut on peut entendre le projet
intellectuel théorique de les
souffrances d'hier avec les souffrants
d'aujourd'hui et la manière dont on les
transcende avec l'europe aujourd'hui
enfin bref ok très bien je suis pas
certain quand même que ce soit le
meilleur moyen de parler simplement en
jean et je pense que quand vous ne vous
êtes pas fait fait engueuler sur un
marché parce que vous êtes un élu
justement vous avez une tendance à ne
pas savoir comment vous adresser aux
questions qu'il ne faut pas mépriser
elles sont pas trivial changèrent le
quotidien des français c'est quoi et la
même chose cette espèce de mélange des
genres entre eux la réponse à donald
trump qui peut être effectivement
justifier et les gelées jaune je trouve
que ça affaiblit et l'un et l'autre
aspect abordé ce soir et on doit
s'arrêter merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir été avec nous pendant une heure
en direct sur public sénat merci d'avoir
participé à ce numéro très spécial
caroline michel aguer je rappelle le
titre de l'offre qui sort demain en
kiosque pouvoir d'achat qui perd qui
gagne le magazine fait le point c'est
donc la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve demain comme d'habitude en
direct dès 18h30 sur public sénat
l'invité de territoire d'infos demain
c'est mounir majidi secrétaire d'état au
numérique très bonne soirée reste au
coeur du débat
non
[Musique]